Okay.
Hello and welcome everyone.
It is January 28th.
20, 22.
We're here in Acton
Flat Model Stream number 5.1
with Pietro Marseglia and Tim Verboten.
So this is going to be a model stream
presentation
and discussion on their recent work
Contrastive Active Inference.
We're going to have a presentation
section and then discussion.
So please feel free to ask any questions
during the presentation
that we can address in the discussion.
And Tim and Pietro, thanks a ton.
We really appreciate you
joining to share your work.
So please take it away.
And thanks again.
Yeah, thanks, Daniel,
for inviting us as well.
So I'm going to be able to get the better
we are going to work on.
Interesting of interest.
So let me first
set the scene.
Why are we looking at active inference
or basically our lab
wants to build convergence agents?
And so from that perspective, the studio
and if you want to build something
indulgent, it needs to be involved.
It needs to be interacting
with its environments.
And then most of those
interactive
instruments are basically your agents to
your environment.
It's interacting with.
And you need to build the model,
basically.
So are first
give an overview of active inference
and the way that the three are
and a little
this material is also being covered
in a previous middle stream,
I think number three.
So if you want more details,
you can think of that one again.
And so then afterwards
gets over and he will go to the nitty
gritty details
of the contrasting approach of inference.
So let's get started.
So basically active
inference,
it's a process theory of the brain.
And basically it says that your brain
or your agents
build or
you build this model of the environment,
which is basically the joins probability
distribution over that observation.
So things that you can see or experience
actions which we do know the state
and then states or
states of the universe.
So basically you have your agents
that separate from the environment
and its actions interact
with the environment.
And this gives rise to new observations.
And so the idea of the ball
is agents for out,
which are kind of the hidden states.
That's the change by actions
and the different ways
to my observations.
And if you can build such a model,
then basically this enables
the agents to plan some actions
to to bring the agent
to some preferred observations
or outcomes and so forth.
But so the crucial bits is basically
how do you get this model
of what happens if I do my actions?
How does this influence the states
and how does this influence the
outcomes that I see?
So the crucial for from experience
is twofold.
First of all, the key is what the agent
does in a decision optimizing so-called
free energy, which is a profound
surprise, a prediction error.
So basically,
if Joe, this model allows the agent
to predict the outcomes,
that it will see that true witness and
the better
this match your actual observations,
the more happier you are as an agent.
And crucially,
you will also select the actions
that will minimize the frequency
you expect in the future.
And so we think of this to the models
just to to set the scene.
On the one hand, the reason
why so that we all know for
the system is for this also to then
see the move the jet will make
from the let's see value
act of influence presentation
thoughts more countries
the formulation of the of
interest free energy object
So we start off with
setting to see what the genesis model so
it's it's a bit
laid out the diagram of the agents
and the environments
that was on the previous slide.
So basically this unfolds over time.
So you are in certain states
that gives rise to certain observation
and then given an action
on your previous state and basically move
ahead to the next stage
and this process unfolds over time.
And you can see some of the
circles are colored gray.
And these are basically
the things that you can observe.
So, you know, the actions,
if you did that until now,
as you know,
the observations that you saw until now
and all the rest
is basically for you to infer.
So you can only infer it in states
until now,
but you can also try to infer
the hidden states of the future.
Actions that you want to take or
d'observation that you will experience.
And so basically that
the so-called junk
model joined distribution
over the sequence of observation states.
And action is then
basically characterized as follows.
So you have propriety over actions
you have a license model. So
so yeah. So your prior overreaction.
So this basically versus
what is appropriate
if you take certain actions or time
you have some transition probabilities.
So what is the probability
that I will transition to this next stage
given my previous state and this and
you have the accurate model, which basis?
Yeah, given the state I am
which observation, I will see.
And so it is basically the versus
the so-called Markov assumption.
That's your observation that you see
at this time
that it only depends on your hidden state
and it does not really directly
depend on anything else
because if you know your
if your your current in state, then
you know your observation, you will see
so that basically what is reflected here.
But of course, as an agent
having this model
this allows you to still to to assess
how likely is a sequence of observations,
for example, and allows you to predict
given these actions
what will happen with one crucial
but of course is still
the inverse of this model.
Given that I saw these observations
that are these actions,
which is my current state,
and this is basically non-trivial.
So even if you have the exact model
that you refer to as
this is typically intractable.
So that's why it makes of inference.
You resort to variation inference
that you just say, okay,
I just assume that I can build a model,
the so-called for,
for example, your model.
And this is the thing that will tell you,
given certain observations,
what is my probability to begin a sort of
this what's depicted here?
So you do this.
Q And Q is basically a variation
of your distribution contours
and you just say, okay,
given some observation
I want to have the best estimates
for the state I am in.
And the reality principle
just sits, if that's what you want,
then this is and you just optimize
the free energy, which is no pressure
and basically expectation over
states and generated by your
your expectation over to the difference
between the what an accurate
or your approximate posture
and look like use false the drive model
and if you can minimize deaths,
that basically means that you will have
the best explanation for any observations
you see.
But at the same time, you also have
the best approximate posterior
for the true and you're not going to go
to the whole derivation of this flow
but basically
you can convert this
through to the second regression line.
And this is the one that we use
most often
in our models
which is basically the virgin between
this and the approximate posterior.
So basically what is the state
I am given your observations
that so and
described as basically just this is my,
my guess that I am in the States
given the previous state elections.
So I don't know the observation
but I want to test this
without my observation.
And if I see your observation, I don't
want my beliefs to completely switch
because the probability
there's something wrong with my model.
And then you have the second term,
which is the,
the looks like this
basically the accuracy of your model
or how good are you at
reconstructing the outcomes.
And so
this is all form to false
basically or control your current events
that so you know, your observations
do so now you can validate the energy
and then you can be
a predictor model in order to
minimize this thing.
But of course
you also need to know your actions.
You want to get to the future.
And so if you look into the future,
then talk about the expected energy.
So here we didn't we
we use by the shorthand
for the sequence of actions
into the future that also switched from D
to just to denote that we are talking
about future type steps basically.
But the same with the important business
now that in the expectation
now you don't have expectation
it's only over states
with also over outcomes
because you couldn't sense
your observations yet.
So you don't know them so you can just
do an expectation over
anything that could happen.
And, and then the move
that is made in
the conference is basically that's
the on hand for the term
which they call the instrumental value
or realizing preferences.
And it's basically stating
that as an agents for future outcomes
they have some prior
they think that they will regardless
what happens that I think I will realize
it's kind of your your preferred
outcomes let's say can also cross
this more like homeostasis.
So my body temperature can be
37 degrees Celsius.
So my expectation before
knowing anything is that it will be
37 degrees and hence
I will act in order to make it so.
So that's a bit reflexive here
that disregards the
the dependency on your reaction
that you just say,
okay, my prayer
is that this is what I expected.
So this becomes the instrumental value.
And then the second,
the solution is basically that
your approximate
just your model is basically very,
very close to the studio
so that you have a good approximation.
Then you can reside in the second term,
which basically means
that you have on the one hand and
the third that's says,
this is my belief or the state
given injections I will do.
And the other thing
is also a belief about future states
have an actions and some certain outcomes
that I expect to see.
So basically it says
what would be the information that I gets
from looking for certain outcomes.
And it's it's kind of in a systemic value
or information
gain which can drive you to explore.
Basically,
you want to have if, if you don't know
how to get to your preferred state,
at least you want to get to state as to
states that give you more information
on where you are
and go, first of all, often says
it's like the owl that needs fruits.
So what do you do with the first order
you search for pre first.
And so the epistemic value
is basically searching for prey.
It's like where should I go to do
to get more information on this
and then once you know where this
then you can realize your preferences
and the thought is that
there was a pretty risk
so how does the action selection works
then?
Well, basically
you want to select the actions
that minimized your expected strategy.
So at each times, the first thing you do
is you use your model to
estimate your return.
States like knowing which state
may now given my latest observation,
then you can evaluate
the expected free energy for
for each of also your plans
for a future sequence of actions
you can evaluate
and expect to be energy.
And then this basically results
in a belief over policy.
So you basically take the the mind,
the negative energy, you're multiplied.
It's this precision parameter
which just states how yeah.
How how much confidence you have.
The energy is correct basically.
And then you use this
the suffix so basically it just
it just says
the the
policies that have low expected
tree energy are the ones that are
most likely basically that's that's
the only thing is from the source
and then referred in this section,
according to this, you just select
the next section for the sequence
that you think will really give you the
the minimum energy
and that side of course.
And then you take this action,
you get a new observation and the process
is and so one crucial point
in all our work
is that it all starts with this
just following is a flexible and
typically
you can and you have a certain problem
and you know how the problem
looks like, what the observations are or
what the hidden state might be.
And then you can really pinpoint
and write down the exact model
and so optimizing.
But in our case,
this is often the true issue.
If you look at the robots
that drives around
and gets them right inputs, for example.
Yeah, well, these are
the states things that you need to
track.
How do you
convert these pixels to the state space?
So all these things are there.
They're just not there.
You have the goal in a work
is, yeah, I can
then completely start from scratch
and learn this and for listening
the use of neural networks
to access, function, approximate
or actually
provide the smoothness, these models
optimize
the parameters of these neural nets
also by minimizing the energy.
That's that's great. That's it.
So how does it look like all this?
Not will.
So we start off with observations
and actions so this can be but
pixels basically so
and and by matrix of numbers
let's see actions
which could be any action
could your whole city or whatever
your agent can do
and these numbers are put into a neural
net which we told you in order
and this basically reflects
this Brooks's posterior.
This is just saying given my previous
action and my observation outputs
probabilistic presentation
which is basically the means
and the variances of the very patients.
And then we have a second rule
that's rich called transition model.
And this is then
so yeah, well,
what will happen if I do a certain action
out of my state evolves.
If I say to a certain action Now
finally, we also have the decoder
or the electric model, the then outputs
given the State's observation.
So in case of an image, for example,
this will generate you a new image.
And the goal is of course to
have the best predictions possible.
So if you look at the energy forms,
again, in this case
it's again you have this like in the form
which basically just says
that during the output of the decoder.
So to generate image,
I just want to have this close
to the actual image that you've been.
See, so it's just a reconstruction
lost in terms of neural nets, let's say.
And the second to
sort thinking through on a scale
killer verges
between the distribution
that you generate from the encoder
and the distribution
that you generate from the transition.
Well, it's
so we apply this on a number of cases,
which also
we're seeing
in the previous model stream.
So just to give you some intuitions,
the first thing was
the multiple problems,
just which is the basic control problem.
So here
the sensory input,
that's the position you are
you basically have to infer
not only the position
you're in, but also the momentum
you have the most you have.
And so you can see that
on the right,
you can see the model predicting
all likely trajectories
for going left or right.
And you can see how in the beginning it's
not sure on the course.
So it's it's very spread out
and and what it will predicts.
But the more information that gets,
the more kind of collapses.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure that
this is the behavior this will happen.
And then you can use this tool
to drive the agents towards
the preferred states.
In this case, the, the flag
the second one was using
the quarries or environments or here
you get these
observations that are now
just pixels from from this game
and the preferred state of the car
will still be in the central metric.
And so you can see how it actually infers
the actions that will
bring it to the central district.
And it might even cut corners
in order to the reach
of preferred states
a bit faster And finally,
we also have this fun on the robots
navigating our lab
where encrypted
with the number of sensor mobility
so you can see the camera,
but also from tracing
lighter and also very dark range Doppler.
So the radar range Doppler
basically gives you
in the way access the range
and in the x axis,
the the velocity of the reflections,
basically the Doppler
and here
you can see how in the beginning,
if it has been a number of situations
and then basically that the model imagine
what would happen.
So these are real observations
and now it basically imagines
what it will see if it turns around,
for example, and just yet actually learns
basic dynamics, basic behavior
of of all the sensor model.
So that's pretty cool
So what
are the limitations of this thing?
Well, there are two core limitations
that we address
in the first one is
that we use this this six
X reconstruction both to learn the model,
but also to define
your preferred status like
this is the image that you want to see
and try to make that happen.
But the problem is that this great error
in pixel
in terms of pixels
is not really the best metric.
So, for example,
if you have the the left image
and you look to assist output
an image is similar to that one.
We have two examples you on the right
and you can see that's the same image
with some salt and pepper
and those is actually scoring worse
in terms of squared error
than an image where the two
the joint arm is actually
incorrect.
So although in terms of behavior,
the left one is better
in terms of great error
the right one is better.
So that's of course problematic.
If you want to control the arm,
the words to go
and on seconds limitations
that if you need to evaluate
the expected free energy for the huge
number of potential trajectories,
potential actions you can do,
then of course this becomes intractable
as the number increases.
And so the the ways that we go
through this in the context of work
is on the one hand, instead of
using a pixel wasting constriction
or just compressive learning,
it sets out exactly
this works with performance
and in the next few sites.
And then the second thing is instead of
evaluating
the expected the energy for all this,
you basically
amortize the forces actions.
So we also train neural nets outputs,
actions, different stages.
And so with that,
we can now shift to get through.
Google talked about the contrastive
formulation of the expected
benefits from.
Thank you, Tim.
All right.
So thank you, Daniel, for having us.
And thank you, Tim.
You know, if you can hear me well,
soon on
my screen out
Okay.
All right.
So now I would think about
our recent work contrasted in France.
So this work was recently published
that noted
that those in 31
very recently
nice months.
Let's start delving into it.
So the
dissecting that we discuss
in inductive inference is very similar
to the reinforcement learning.
One with the difference
that in reinforcement learning,
the old behavior
learning is driven by rewards.
So the agent receive reward function
and the positive rewards
should reinforce positive behaviors
while negative.
The rewards should penalize
the agents
to avoid those states and actions.
However, one of the problems that comes
with reinforcement learning is that
in order to actually learn from rewards,
you need a reward function.
And that's not always easy to have
For instance, as you mentioned,
especially when the state
is not known in advance,
so the agent don't exactly know
its status is difficult.
In that case,
the design, the reward function, because
you're not sure of what the agent knows
and how it can assess its performance
compared to the environment.
So we
instead focus on active inference
in the inference the agents operates
to that the principle of minimizing
free energy as we have
just so that the principle
of minimizing free energy
actually enables two things.
The one thing is to learn a model.
The work We call this an artificial work
model where work seems simple.
And the other objective is to minimize
the free energy future
by trying to achieve
some preferred outcomes of the agent.
So we assume that the agent
does some preferred outcome distribution
that he wants to achieve
and that this goal will be in the future
to actually achieve
these preferred outcomes.
So the
the environmental setting we discuss
is that one of the options
piece of partially observable
market is in process.
So just to recap the observation
that the agent
receives, just infer the internal state
of the environment which is not served.
And then there's action
which are actually known for the past,
but the agent should infer
or somehow choose
among a set of possible action
in the future.
So this is just a summary
of what
the artificial word module looks like,
or as we've seen in the previous lights,
we have an encoder that
the information from observation
we focus on visual environments.
So here we have again an image
which is basically owned by metrics,
or the encoder could be, for instance,
a convolutional neural network
In our case,
we have the the even state model
with which takes the previous state
and the previous action
and in particular no work.
You use some some form of recurrent
neural network model
in order to keep preserving
the history of the environment.
And then we have the decoder that
computes reconstruction
of the information on the current state.
So it tries to encode
inside that
in the States as much information
not possible
from what it comes
from the from the observation.
So the problem with
reconstruction is that computing then
especially in visual
environments is is quite complicated
because you need a
big models that there are very good
representational capacity.
And also the models cannot be 100%
accurate.
I think that low low dimensional settings
because for instance, predicting
an image pixelbypixel
is practically very invisible.
So it's very rarely happens.
So let's call an example
a year or so, a few a few weeks ago
I was a I was training to be like models.
So like a model similar
to this one on the left.
So where we have the this encoder
decoder architecture on that.
Well, and I'm thinking the breakout game
and try to to learn and even state to
to learn action on top of the interstate.
The problem is that
the reconstruction of the V
so we're actually pretty bad
in that they we're losing very important
information about the game.
So for instance it was kind of able
so we some uncertainty to model
where the model of the game is
but it wasn't able
to model where the ball easy
which is actually one of the two
most important details
in order to actually be able to play.
So even adding the reward function
in this case so having the the
the game score available
and the agent wasn't able
to learn the task because of of the state
which was lacking
the most important information
in order to to keep improving.
So this is one issue
that we try to overcome in our work.
And the second part of active interest
involves
learning to pursue the preferred outcome.
So in order to pursue
preferred outcomes active in agent,
the two things, one tries to minimize a
the distance
with respect to two disparate outcomes.
But then the other way
you also minimize the ambiguity
with respect to the environment
So normally this is done
by trying to match the,
the two distributions
or trying to match, as we saw,
even if we've scaled divergence
to match the distribution of the match,
the outcome with the preferred
outcomes, distribution, whatever.
Again, in a dimensional setting,
this can be quite complex
because how do you define a distribution
in an aid nation or here much
could it be, for instance, just
the center go around the, the big self.
So we've the
with the mean being the pixel value
and then some fixed extend the deviation.
But in that case we we get into troubles
because we have the same issue
discussed before we for instance
have this kind of goal here
and a noisy observation like this
which actually adds an eye.
Another means square error
compared to to an image
that is very distant from the goal.
And this kind of situation,
especially when using reconstruction
or in more realistic settings, are very,
very likely because for instance, you
can you can see that the center image
is actually
just a reconstruction of the model,
which is not under percent accurate.
So that could be the case.
And indeed, the agent could be confused
and you will think that is not achieving
the goal compared to maybe,
for instance, a bus observation.
But if it seemed that
it was actually actually closer
to the goal or again, when there is some
some noise in the environment
in real set up like the robotic,
we always have
this noise in the observation
so it's our to
to match our preferred outcome
in, you know, even national setting.
So we we also try to
to overcome this issue here
So what we do propose is to use contrast
learning a conservative learning is a
is a mechanism
popular in the in unsupervised
learning scene that we will discuss
more in depth in a few moments.
So the the the objective that we want to
where we want where
there are to avoid reconstruction
in learning the word model.
So we don't have any more of the decoder
here as we see on the right.
Then we want to be able to match
preferred outcomes in the lower
dimensionality space
because we have seen that it's
no dimensionality that's problematic.
And also we we would like the
this low dimensional state to be somewhat
representative of the task
so that when we match our goals
in this low dimensional state,
we are actually doing something
that actually brings us closer
to the actual preferred outcome that we
we want to achieve
in the high dimensional setting.
So let's let's try to compare
to see what are the difference in between
using the likelihoods
to the inference model.
And the contrasting models.
So the idea in the likelihood
actually inference model
is that we want to maximize
the accuracy of reconstruction.
So basically this this means that we have
this decoder that maximizes this
maximum likelihood of the observation
given the state.
So we want the state to to
maximize the information
that it contains about the observation.
Basically, in contrast, learning
we in contrast, deductive inference,
we do something different.
So instead of trying to reconstruct
the current observation,
we try to compress
the encoder again, this observation
and compare it to all of the other
not all the other, as we will see
in a while, because that's visible,
but in many, many other samples
that represent something different.
So that we in the, in the late in space,
in this compressed space,
we want our a state
and the compressed
image to be very close.
And while this our state should be very
distant from all the other hemorrhages.
So we
we are indeed maximizing the similarity
with this
and with the corresponding sample that
this is here called the positive sample
where we want to minimize
the similarities
and maximize the distance
against all the other samples
that are called negative samples
in contrasting learning.
So as we'll see also in in a moment, this
this mechanism here maximizes the lower
bound of the mutual information.
So we are basically trying to maximize
the information in between
corresponding observation in state while
minimizing the information with respect
to the all the other negative spurts
so as we seen
before, the the free energy bus can be
summarized with this equation here.
So here I'm just
talking about one time,
one moment in this for ten steps.
So instead the team presented
for all sequences by using the field
the notation.
Well, here we're just considering
one time steps the time.
So as we as we have seen
the free energy is basically are
an upper bound
on the appraisal information
that we would want to minimize.
So we minimize free energy in order
to minimize this appraisal of the agent.
And the year is it's actually evident
that we have this evidence on.
So the 80 scale diverged into these old
where there are equal to zero.
We wanted to basically to to reach zero
hypothetically in order to minimize these
this evidence bound.
And this can also be repeated
in a way
that is more practical implemented.
So by having the the likelihood
of the observation given the state
which actually means
the accuracy of our model
and that again
the complexity of the model
which is the close divergence between
our variation variational distribution.
Q Which we, we use.
Q Oh, that's given all
which is basically using the outgoing
coding variation of relational
posterior.
So this is
as typical
as a stunning in variational encoders.
So when you
when you try to infer the parameters
of your posterior distribution
by using the corresponding observation,
and then we we want to minimize the close
divergence between this out coded
posterior and the our prior
about the about the, the,
the current or future states
we can say given the boss
state and actions
and the in our case in particular
we generally learn this this frame.
So we don't just use
a uniform
prior overstate but
we will learn our years to be predictive
of what the state is given the bus state.
So it can basically seem like
if we're machine learning in particular
as a, as a conditional variation
of encoder,
we've, we've contrastive learning
what we try to do
is as I said, to
maximize state similarity
with the correct and corresponding
observations over
could sample
while minimizing with the other
and this means again
that we want to maximize
the neutral information
between the positive sample
and the corresponding state and minimize
the information
with the negative samples.
This can be written like this or
the noise contrastive estimation.
So noisy here.
That's the abbreviation
basically provides a again,
a lower bound
and the neutral information.
So where we where we see
that we basically have like a soft marks.
So over the over all the the
the observation
is state what does it mean?
So for each pair of state
and observation,
we run this volume.
So the value of this critique
is that this critical function F
to be as high as possible
or we want it to be
a very low respect to the other
so that actually the exponential of these
a compared to the sum
of all the other exponential is either
with the corresponding dissipation
and very low with the rest.
So this is basically saying that the
if you want matching bears
to be to be very close
and distant bassoon
to a very, very low value.
And the the this is lower
bound is a is an approximation
normally when we take a number of samples
key from that
a joined distribution that we define
between X
and Y in particular in our case is X
and Y
represent our observation
and our in the States.
So we define a priori these
disjoint distribution
to actually represent
the fact that these state corresponds
to this observation
and we want to maximize the information
in between them
and the function F, x,
y again
is so so-called critique function.
So what does it mean is a function
that should approximate the log density
ratio that we see here on the right
I won't go into the mathematical
details of these,
but basically is a mapping of the
of the the two inputs so basically
the mapping of our observation
and our state
and we want these again
these outputs to be I
for corresponding bursts and the and load
for non corresponding bursts.
So how do we
transition
from the free energy of the path
that we have seen to the
to our contrastive formulation
still what the the first step that we do
is adding to the to the free energy
functional as a term that we
we assumed to be constant the despair,
the entropy of the observation.
So how can we assume that the entropy
of the observation is constant?
So in machine learning,
we generally have a data set
from which we sampled
our observation about the past.
So we assume when we train
that our data set
so that the distribution
of the observation is fixed
so the entropy of this distribution
will always be a constant
because we can modify that.
I suppose for instance, to the States
which
which means that so the distribution
of our outcomes cannot be modified.
And so its entropy is a constant.
If we add disturbance
to the free energy functional,
we can rewrite it
as a, as the coiled divergence
minus this information
gain or mutual information here
between the states and the observation.
So given this, we can now
apply the fact that we in
contrast, keep learning
a functional this is a lower
bound on the mutual information
to actually derive the
the free energy of the past
where expecting all the terms result
according to the previous light nets.
We basically have, again,
this coiled divergence there.
And then we have
this the value of F between all
and this to maximize
and then to minimize all the
again the
the value of the function of with respect
to all the other negative spurts
So this brings those two
to again
an upward bound on this appraisal term.
We see that this upward bone
is actually even higher
than the normal free energy,
upper bound bus as we'll see later.
These are some nice property. Does it
explicitly help us to get
rid of the reconstruction and to learn
a different representational space?
It does some advantages compared to the
to the likelihood
based representation
So let's now talk about how can we learn
to behave using constructive inference.
So in the likelihood based active
inference model, what we were trying to
maximize was again,
the likelihood of the future observation,
but under the preferred distribution.
So we want to
we want the imagined outcomes
to be as close
as possible
to the two that outcomes that we prefer
a So these for
these are environment in place that we
we reconstruct
what the what we imagine will happen
in the dimensional space.
So that emerge basically.
And then we compare it
to our preferred image, for instance.
And as we see
before we can for instance, use
a mean squared error distance
or we can just use like
we can just go
down and compute the likelihood
under the preferred the distribution
or contested up to the inference.
We again instead
use a contrasting mechanism when we want
now the the future state
to be corresponding with our
samples from the preferred distribution.
So we want the,
the outcomes that we prefer
to actually be a close to there
to the state that we imagined so that now
we don't need anymore to reconstruct
what the what
the outcome of our action will look like.
But we can just say is the,
the state that we match in matching with
the preferred outcome
that they want to achieve.
And the that's, that's what we,
we maximize similarity with.
And again, we also have some
some form of the ambiguity minimization
or epistemic value
in trying to minimize
the similarity respect to other outcomes.
So in this case, minimizing
the similarity in respect to outcomes
that are not in the preferred
distribution
basically means that the other want to go
far from something
that you have already seen before
in order to maybe
get closer to the
the preferred the outcomes,
or you either
just want to minimize your ambiguity.
So you want to be as far as possible
from other outcomes in the schools
as possible through that to the actual
preferred outcome view
that you're opting for.
So as we have seen
before, the expected free energy
can be summarized like this.
I'll first highlight
some difference in respect to
the equation the team present that.
So first of all year
we we take action to be part
of the of their active entrance process.
So they aim for the process.
Well,
and before we have seen that, you can
you can have a distribution
of our policies and then you can
you can sample the action
from the policy and
and compute
the free energy of the future a given
a posterior on your
on a policy when I give them policy
instead here
we make the the actions part of the
the generative models for the future
and we actually want the agent to insert
the injection for the future
and not just compute them as a
as a posterior of our over some
distribution of the over the policies.
So we we have enough in the posterior
is this 18
so we that we inferred both the
the the future state
and the future election
and also the the prior
other over the preferred outcomes
that indicates we feel that
I have this not confusing before
because before the deal
that was used to indicate sequences
by in the paper I actually use it to
to indicate the preferred outcome
so yes notation issues
but I hope there's not confusing.
So that is basically to
say if this is the preferred
distribution over
observation state and explain
and so this is basically
our target distribution what we what
we hope to achieve in the future
and we can rewrite this as a
as the sum of three terms.
So we have this.
So first of all I'm assuming
that's the agent's us
no prior preference in action
so that for him
any action that will bring it
to the preferred outcomes it's fine
so he has a uniform prior but action
so the action doesn't really matter
it is as long as it brings to there
to the goal let's see.
And the so this in this way
we we obtain an action and be
and then the rest the intrinsic value is
that is the same epistemic party
that we've seen before. And
so the the one that the
obligation
to to explore the environment more
or either to reduce this ambiguity
about the environment.
And then we have the extrinsic value
which is basically rewards
or just
just a way to get closer to the,
to the actual preferred outcomes
so that the value to pursue
in order to minimize distance
from the from the preferred outcomes
in our competitive expected free energy,
we we again to assume there moves
as we did from the past.
So we assume that we are taking
interpretation over
our preferred outcomes since we don't
imagine outcomes in the future,
we just assume that the outcomes will
will be according to the
so the preferred outcome situation
so that we can again sum
the entropy over our fixed
preferred outcome distribution.
And then the steps are the same.
So we, we have again
this mutually information term
between the preferred outcomes
and the, the state that we mentioned
in the future and the, the, the action
and should be determined the
scale divergence
between the still other states
and the other states.
So is
a complex term
I'd say,
because it basically should represent
and the difference between what the, what
the agent believes it will happen and,
and what is supposed to happen
in the environment.
So normally in active inference,
we assume
for the future that the
the model of the world is correct
so that the agent does not control
of the over word model.
So it cannot change how the
the environment dynamics will transition
from one state to another.
So I, I'm assuming year that
this is this scale divergence in terms
actually zero though
I've seen that some work
this could also be built left
there are being greater than zero
but then then it's basically
adding the agent imagines that they can
then it can violates the the environment
dynamics hoping for a better dynamics
that it will allow it to
to be optimistic
and think yet the thing that I imagine
it will happen
is actually going to happen so either we
we don't allow the agent to
to modify or the environment to move from
one state to another and we just assume
yeah these are the dynamics
and betterment so our posterior over the
in the transition
dynamics of the environment is correct.
And so the scale diverging in zero
and then our objective again doing the
applying the the contrastive the learning
lower bound translates into this
when we we have these contrasting
mutually information
between the preferred outcomes and the is
this action entropy term.
So if you write out explicitly we again
have this this to term
which kind of reminds
the two extrinsic value
and intrinsic value
for for the free energy.
So we have this
the term that actually there should
minimize the similarity
with the negative sample
that is doing something similar
to what the the intrinsic value in in
active inference should do.
So basically are trying to
to be distant from from previously seen
their outcomes.
This is kind of similar to explore the
environment to minimize your ambiguity.
So try to find something that gives
you more information, not something
that you have already seen
and so the, the,
the word model can be summarized in
these three main components
that we learn.
We have our prior network that,
as I said before, is learned.
And Schiller should learn the,
the transition dynamics
of the environment
so trying to predict future states,
given the US states and actions.
And then we have this jury yourself
that is shared between the
the prior and the Posture Network.
And this is what allows us
to brings our history both.
So it just not stuck
to the previous state,
but also to include some information
about previous states
so that we have more, more information
available in order
to infer
what the current state is actually is.
Then we have our posterior network,
which also has access
to the that observation
and the disclosure.
CNN, as a as I mentioned,
is a convolutional neural network.
And the yeah, here
we have the actual layered description
for our environments, which are 64 by 64.
But that's that's less important.
The important thing is
that we have a convolutional model
that compresses the formation
from the observations for us.
And these same convolutional network
is also linked
to the,
to the representation model that is this
the, the critique of the contrastive
learning mechanism.
So the function that is indeed
matching states and the observation
in order to learn the good
contrastive learning representation.
So the, the function of that
we minimize and respect
the past is a is our contrasted
free energy of the past, some over
an arbitrary number of, of these key
time steps in the over
past the sequences.
It is important to say that
for the past there
the negative samples that we take
are an observation
of the of
of the same sequence of the object
corresponding observation.
So that said that we have an observation
in the States
the negative samples will be
on the other observation within the same
sequence that are not the same in time,
but also observation
that come from, from other sequences.
So, so that we are basically contrasting
the, the
current
state with the different time steps.
So what happened in different
the moment of the
of the same sequence of actions and the
what happened in different situations.
So different sequences
and that's how we, we try to,
to foster
our contrastive learning mechanism.
Then we have the action models.
So for our action model,
we have two networks.
One is the so called action network,
which basically inverse
to the, the action to take a given state.
And then we have this expected
activity network and this helps
us pursuing what the team anticipated
so that the fact that we we are
amortizing the action
selection process for very
long term sequences by using
a network that should estimate
what the the value of a certain
state is in the future.
So I'll try to be more more clear here.
So basically the action network to
minimize these
this G lambda
a functional
that is basically an estimate
that of
of how much value is in a certain states.
And although we get this estimate
so the estimate is
is provided by this formula here.
So basically at every step
we provide the the actual expected
a competitive free energy for that state
and then for the future
the we we some
we compromise in between an estimate
of what the what the network would
predict is going to
is going to be the value in the future.
And the, the, the value itself
that we are that we are computing
we there with the functional
so that the baby steps we basically
sum the value that we we
expect in the step there
we bootstrap this.
That's the way
we normally see reinforcement learning.
So we we apply some form of dynamic
programing approach to
to sum this value with what we expect
will happen in the future
and the we use these
as our target for learning the estimate.
So we basically have the estimate
and the estimate of the future
plus the current value.
And we compare the two when we want the,
the actual estimates to be closer
to what is actually happening
plus the future estimate.
And this is this is actually what is
normally done in reinforcement learning.
When you apply the the so-called
bellman equation in order to estimate
what's going to happen in the future
by using what you actually know.
So generally like the rewards
and in our case, the, the explicit
free energy value and what you
you can estimate for the future
so you know, we're experiments
we compare to
we compare four flavors that
make for reinforcement
learning using likelihood model.
This is very measured
the dealer baseline.
So the those are likely based
and they're the word model and
it uses rewards for learning action.
So the the river song
freeze is already given to the agent.
And then we compare it
with contrastive drama.
It is a modification of primary
using a contrastive
a learning for this word
modeling sort of reconstructions
and then we compare the two flavors
of active inference
in the standard and see one
with the likelihood reconstruction model
and our contrastive formulations
so we use similar architecture
and training routine
for all the different baselines in the
training routine.
Can be summarized
as we see here in so the code.
So for certain
and for a certain amount of number
of training steps that we if it's events,
we are going to train our work model
on the previous experience.
So now on a replay buffer
that basically represents
our data sets of plus experiences,
then we are going to use
the trained words model
to imagine some trajectories
in the future by using
our actually model
and the replay buffer as well,
which is used because we need to take
the negative samples
for the contrastive
pre energy functional.
And then on the imagined trajectories,
we are going to train our
our action model in order to actually
try to pursue the the preferred outcomes
better.
And then we are going to go back to
the environment, collect a new trajectory
using our word models to infer
what the what the even state of
the of the environment is at
and everything step and using the action
model to select the action
according to the state of tweaking first
and then add to the just collected
trajectory to the data set.
And we do this continuously.
So train the word model.
Imagine some trajectories
and the train the action model and again
keep collecting so that we
we continuously improve
both the data collection process
because the the the word model
and the actual model gets better
and also our modeling needs
so that we get closer to the goal
So one important insight
into the person to produce
before turning into an
and vertical evaluation of the method
is the fact that the using control scheme
learning strongly reduces the the
computational requirements of the model.
So a year
high and comparing the number of
multiple
million
models can play a clinician operation.
And for our models
and the number of parameters
that we as we see these are much lower
when we use a contrastive
mechanism
compared to the using likelihood model.
And the addition
is also reflected in terms where dinosaur
our model is quite clustered
compared to the dreamer
that the things things the likelihood
based model for the world uses
just rewards for learning action
and is much, much
faster than the likelihood the active
inference model because they like
you are not giving trends model
other than adding to to the
the reconstruction during the world
model training also us to imagine
the the eye
dimensional outcomes in the future.
So in that case
you have even more computation
because for every margin trajectory
you have to imagine all the possible
images in our context that you are you in
you will get pursuing a certain
a certain policy.
So it's our model
is quite faster than that.
So the first star
that I will discuss
is the simple mini task.
So the agent represents the
the red arrow through
the navigate are black white
in order to reach Venus Square.
The display is
in one of the corner of the grids.
So the environment is partially observed
because the agent doesn't know
what's in every pixel of the grid.
So in order to find the gold
first issued the explorer,
the old grid and, and find the,
the Green Square or at least
be in a position that allows in to
to see the Green Square in front of them.
So for the further you what model
of course we have,
we have the highest reward and the in
correspondence of the of the gold states.
So when the when the agent
is actually on the on the gold square,
it will receive a reward of plus one
and this is a sparse reward task.
So for all the other states the edge
and that will just
receive volunteer rewards.
So it will be just
good still to reach the goal
was for active interest method.
The way that they chose to define
the preferred outcome
is to have an image of the agent
that is that sees himself on the goal.
So basically the agencies
in cells on the goal and says
this is the position
that they want to reach in the world
and let's see
what happens from our
from a qualitative level.
So as I said before,
the rewards for this task
is just a plus one in the right, a
in the right square in the goal square.
What happens for the
the active insurance model?
So what we'll do?
The active inference
model provides us a value of a certain
status of the agents in order to
to pursue the preferred outcome
so we see that the like
new active inference when
the is
imagining the outcome and comparing it to
the preferred images
is actually giving a very I value for the
for the right
the square saw this the you know
go from 01 we can say that it's the 10
sorry we can say that's the one
but other than that the the function
that it is providing is a bit confusing
because it's giving some other rewards
in the sentence
compared to the let's say the the
the the last row and column
that are the one that leads the
to the final goal.
The the the other corner
are not even close to the go one.
So it's just the,
it's just providing a perfect match.
And we have no, no control of what
the distance the goal is
because for the perfect match,
the goal that's,
that is indeed the, the correct part
of the biggest providing.
But other than that, we,
it's difficult to understand what the
the the likelihood
that the inference model is providing
with the contrastive up to the inference
we see that there is a different button.
So the agent is providing
very low value for the center.
So it's understanding that the center is
of course not what they want to see
but then is providing AI values
to all the corners
and in particular the highest that is
provided to the air, to the right corner.
So the one with the goal because is
of course the, the one that corresponds
to most with that
we want what we want to achieve.
But then on the other corner
also have a very high value and the
the fact is that from I will say
that the contrast back to inference
is especially capturing a more
I will see
semantic information about environment.
So in order to distinguish a corner
from from a central title
is actually a model in the fact
that there is a corner
in in a certain state of the environment.
And when you look at the preferred
outcome image, you actually says,
first of all, this is a corner
and that's the way distinguishes.
And then there is the green
as the green tile in the
in the in where the where the agent is so
much from a value perspective,
we can say that
a corner is closer in semantics,
respect
to to a central style to our goal.
And then of course,
when you also have the the green tile
which represents the goal, then your
are the closest.
So this is of course a bit risky because
it can also be due to suboptimal behavior
in some cases.
But with the good expression
of the environment that it will
of course, will lead the optimal behavior
because still the
the maximum value is still provided
correctly.
So it's still good
value for the right corner.
But if you didn't see
the other corner of the agent,
will we just go to another corner and
say, okay, this looks similar to the goal
so I'm trying to do something similar
to to what I would like to do, right?
If I didn't see anything else.
Disclosure, this is my the best I can do.
So this is a light.
So exploration is important
in order to to achieve
preferred outcomes.
And I think that's that also applies
to likely reductive inference as well
because even if it see the goal,
you just add some, some noise,
some noise, a signal in the center
so you wouldn't
be able to reach the goal as well.
And then yeah,
we quantified the performance.
We see that with the
with the likelihood active inference
that the agent struggles
to to reach the goal
consistently.
Well, our our methods leads
to consistent performance
that are in line with the reward base
baselines.
Of course, the reward base
baseline have an advantage because
during training
they always have a filtered objective.
So even if their model is not correct,
they always have this reward function
filter function that tells them, yes,
this is where you need to go.
Well,
our model can take a little bit more time
in order to first have a good model
and then being able to match. But
with the
contrastive mechanism,
this actually happens fast
and leads to a consistent performance
where we select the active inference.
We see that it will probably
take more time to converge or
it just leads to the suboptimal behavior.
So it's just inconsistent
according to our evaluation.
And yeah, these are two different
grid environments
where this one is smaller, one is bigger,
but yet the results are very similar
in terms of performance obtained.
Then the other task that we discuss
is our continuous control task.
We've are we've all
to the planner environment
when we're a robotic arm
to the penetrate.
Asked your goals for the the red sphere
and the
the this theory is bigger in the
the so called the return easy environment
which is the one
for which we see the preferred
outcome on the left
and it is smaller for the for
the second feature are the environment
that is the one that we will see
on the right.
So for every work based agent we have
the reward function that provides
the when the agent penetrates
to the sphere solar array was of one.
Otherwise when it's
of penetrating
or just partially penetrating the sphere,
it provides a dense reward.
That's a that tells you
you're getting closer to the goal.
So in this case, the reward function
is actually helping the agent
a bit more because it is telling him
that this is getting closer to the goal.
And he should just try it
in the neighbor area.
And while for the inference
we would just provide the the preferred
staging environment, which is the
the agent penetrating the gold sphere,
and let's see, let's see what happens.
So again, we have a similar
pattern, actually
similar but different
from the previous one or so in this case
where the the main square
there is the distance from the goal
is actually more confusing
as we have seen in previous example.
So the relative
with the active translation totally fails
to to reach the goal because it's
probably the order of the states
looking like an environment
because the background stays the same.
So the background is not moving
as it was happening.
For instance,
for the mini grid environment,
the goal is always in the same position.
So the difference between the two images
is just provide given by the
the few yellow pixels that moves around.
And then if the model is not, imagine
perfectly where this pixel go, it's, it's
very difficult.
It will provide some some informative
or objective for the stars instance.
Our contrastive active inference
agent is able to provide an informative
go and the appearance in the fact that
this providing some semantic information
about the task is actually helping it
to converge even faster than the
than the reward base at baseline
because the reserve based agents
have access to the just
when they are close to the to the goal
or the contrastive activity
first provide a reward function
everybody in the environment.
So when the
when we see that the army is very far
we have the mutual information term
that should basically take over
and don't you yeah.
You don't want to stay there go elsewhere
and the until we
we have only find the ghost here
and we come back to the correct behavior.
So the agent is actually converging
a bit faster than the other base lines
and then yeah.
The the contrastive dreamer
baseline is converging a bit faster
than the remote one because its model is
faster to learn because it's contrastive
so this is what actually happens.
These are a gift on the right.
At some point
they should be able to be said.
So basically we just see here
that the task is that
is correctly executed so that the agent
is, is able to match the,
the correct behavior.
So yeah, he's
taking a bit longer than expected.
But yeah, you can see that the
if for instance, in the in the atas,
the agent oscillates
around the current behavior
but it keeps saying,
okay, here we we see it.
So basically
the Indian environment is oscillating
in the position
that is a very close to the goal.
So it tries to stay as much as possible
to that
it's buoyant and not
not being driven
far from the goal,
but they never show the of the they are
then we
reanalyze qualitatively what's
what's happening in terms of the volume
is provided to the agents or what's
what is the objective
it is given to be to the agent
in order to learn more.
And as as I try to explain,
the reward is
is somewhere in the middle between zero
and one
when the agent
is partially penetrating the goal
and is totally one,
when the agent is fully penetrating,
the goal
in all the other situations is zero
for the active insurance
likelihood based model.
We see that the signal is very close
for all the states.
So the agent basically see things
that there is
very little difference
between being very close to goal
and being actually very far
off from the goal.
And that's
likely the reason why is not converging
to the to the optimal behavior
for contrastive active inference.
Instead,
we see that the agent is provided
an objective variance
some somewhat in between zero
and one when he's there,
when he's not closing the goal.
And something that is very close to one
when it's in the goal and in particular
when when it's closer to the goal,
the, the, the value is actually a bit
higher than when it's when it's far off
so we see that there is some again,
some semantic information provided,
which is the actual distance of the arm
from the from the right goal.
Or we can just see it as an objective
the contrastive learning mechanism
saying, okay, this, this part of the arm
is actually very different
from the one day, the day of today.
So let's try to move to a
place that is actually closer
and the we need of your values when the
when the pause is similar to the two,
the one that we we want to achieve.
So we exploit the fact
that some semantic information
is provided to the agent
by using contrastive
and learning to work on
the more difficult set up is the return
of the starting environment.
So in the visual dissecting task,
we have the same objective as before.
So we want the agent to reach the goal
by penetrating the red sphere.
But now we have our own backgrounds
and we have this structure
in the environment which could be just
altered colors on that camera.
And we still want to to achieve the agent
to still despite that.
So for the, for the reward based agents,
the reward is the same as before.
So they are being provided for the agent
penetrating the ghost here for active.
And for us the goal here is,
is actually a bit troublesome
to the design because given the fact
that the background is constantly
bringing across different episodes,
we cannot a priori define
what's the what
the the preferred outcome looks like.
So instead of doing that,
we attempted providing a more neutral
preferred outcome with the agent,
seeing itself achieving the goal.
But do we have
the standard task background?
So we have this the blue
just like the background
with with the arm penetrating the goal.
And we, we aim for this preferred outcome
to transfer
to the to the destructing set up.
This is of course,
pretty
much impossible for for the likelihood
the active inference model because
our source is trying to match this in the
we have a main square.
There are like functions
of course the signal providing
will be very confusing.
Very interestingly
we see yields that are so the dreamer
method fails because it's based
the on the likelihood based models
and the as we'll see
a reconstruction goal.
The the variations in the environment
is very difficult.
So the the word reconstruction
based work model struggles
to provide
informative states of the environment
while the contrastive learning
based model succeeded in particular.
It's very interesting that our model
was able to to actually achieve the goal
we see less consistently than before
so that there is another variance.
But still the agents is often able
to reach the correct position
despite of the difference
in the background and all the structure
present in the environment.
So we see that this actually
the representation
is actually learning
what the force of the robot should be.
And trying to match it in the future.
And then, yeah,
we see some, some videos with happening.
So we see indeed that the,
the arm is oscillating a bit more slowly.
It's actually a bit more difficult
for him to assess that he's doing
the right thing.
But still the, the behavior obtained
it's still
quite good, I would say.
So it's pretty much achieving the goal
and the dispose why
I like it.
The base
model will fail in this environment.
So here we compared the ground rules
in the different
range backgrounds and the
what the dreamers order them,
the likelihood
the active inference model
sees through the reconstruction.
So we see that either reconstructing
from there, from the procedure state
or from the prior state,
the agent cannot perfectly model
the important information
of the environment,
which in this case is the the arm.
So it sees where the the first
link of the the robot are missed
but he is not able to see it normally
with the second part of the arm.
He is
because is very uncertain about that.
And then and that leads the agent
to do not being able to actually assess
where it is in the environment
and to to provide the
the right value for our
for for what's going on.
So they're using reconstruction
this environment leads to the
to this kind of problem
where the agent is not
certain about the the internal states.
And so it's uncertain
what they should do next
because the signal of the state is
uncertain is computed.
And so it is also the
the value provided by the
but to the agent by the model,
and that's it.
So I'll just briefly summarize
what we have seen.
And so basically,
we use a constructive model
to reduce the computation
here of the objective inference
is also brought some advantages
and enforcement learning.
But yeah, we focus on the on the contract
and the active inference area
where this model brought to
to a twofold advantage
for some learning the the word
model cluster but also in imagining
future trajectories faster
because didn't have the reconstruction.
Then we saw that
the conceptual representational features
the better kept the relevant information
for the environment.
And this was key in solving
both the the research tasks
and especially in the research
disrupting task
where without this feature
we wouldn't be able to solve dusk.
And then we will show that to
we can we can use this method
to provide performance
that are similar to engineering rewards.
But in a much easier way.
So you can just say, okay, this is what
I want to achieve in the environment,
provide the, the observation
the agent engaging will find itself a way
to reach that that state without actually
having to provide a reward function
for every possible space.
The environment
which especially in realistic cases,
is usually unfeasible.
And finally, we
we have also seen that the exploration
is very key for our method to work
because we don't want the agent to
to convert to the suboptimal behavior
that looks like the
the right outcome, the preferred outcome.
So it's it's very important
to wisely explore
the environment
before actually delving into learning the
our preferred policy.
And we
aim to look more into this in the future.
So thank you very much.
That that was it.
I don't know if there's any question.
Thank you both.
Very interesting presentation.
So if anyone watching live
wants to ask a question
otherwise I have a few.
So you mentioned a critic model
when you were describing the architecture
and that reminded me of language
learning.
Like if someone says repeat after me
and then they give a sound, you
might be accurate or you might not be,
but if someone said no, it was not true.
You're a negative and a positive example.
So what does that speak
to perhaps the biological basis
of contrast of learning
or how these contrastive learning
settings act of inference or not
relate to the ways that organisms learn
Okay.
I will say that
the contrastive learning mechanism,
though it's not completely equal.
I was in Somalia in that resembles
the ability mechanism
where you when when when you have
corresponding bursts over.
So the things that should correspond
if you actually want to
to strengthen the link
and when you have stuff that shouldn't
be corresponding you actually you want to
to weaken the link.
So I think that biologically we call
that it could actually seeing this way.
So when you have something that you
you want to be
you want to link farther
in our case
to think that we want to to link further.
So to reinforce is the fact
that this a certain observation
correspond to a certain state
then you just strengthen this connection.
Well, when you where you want
you want to to be far and the square
where the contrast
between it differs maybe from this
that this biological perspective
we actually should be pushed farther
which is not always
the case for it being there
because normally you don't have this
a pushing part of the mechanism.
So I would say this could be
when one possible links
as you said
yeah the critique function is actually
doing something
very very similar to what you mentioned.
So you have a positive samples
and you reinforce the critics tells you
yeah this is this is correct and it sure
tells you that this is correct.
So it's strange to do that
with with with much lower me, but.
Well, if you have a good critique,
you could use that.
But yeah
it should tells you the right samples
while the for for non
corresponding states in the observation
they should go
yeah this is not what we want
in our representation
we want this further.
So maybe to add on Daniel
I think what you're hinting at that's
providing like it should be like
this is more like a way to
to define the preferred state
so so then if you translate it
to do what we are doing it's
basically saying
these observations are
what you should like basically.
So so they come into place for
creating the mobile like
how do they get to these observations.
The contrast off
defrauding for this more like
being
able to distinguish different things
basically
and it's more proof than the difference
but what what you
what you like to what you like
so the contrast different regarding
just learns to distinguish
all kinds of sounds
even all the bad ones and
you can just now say, okay,
but now I really don't have this sound,
so try to get there.
I think that's the difference here.
That kind of sounds like paying attention
to the right details,
which we saw with multiple times
like the breakout games.
Like how could you miss the ball
humans are watching that gif
and we're watching the ball,
but we also have a sense of how to pay
attention to the right details.
And then in terms of action and to have
curiosity about the right things.
So it definitely
starts to
bridge
into some very interesting behavior
Another question was about the action
entropy term
in the free energy calculations.
So maybe could you restate what
the action entropy term is since it's
one of the major contributions?
And also
what does that say about adding terms
to the free energy calculate action
like the action
entropy is always greater than zero.
Kind of like a scale divergence.
And so that you mentioned gives some
perhaps nice properties about the bounded
ness of F within a lower
and an upper bound.
So maybe just
what is the action entropy doing here?
Can we just add other terms
that are bounded zero to free energy
and use that in other ways?
Okay.
So I'll, I'll start with the
with a question about the,
the action entropy term.
And then I also delve into the,
the using different bounds for, for
the free energy term. So
everything is a in the way.
We just added the active inference
process for learning the actions.
The key part is that we
the actions are now part of the,
the future inference process.
So here I could,
I could also go back to the two biggest
like this necessary.
But the normally the way that we see
these objectives
without is a term here and there,
but instead
we have like a conditional
on a policy, on a certain policy.
So normally that means that you,
you have some set of policies already
and you're just trying to decide
which of them is better.
So this could be done like using a
no cameras or not cameras a first
and then
just assessing the the one that you think
are best or just assessing all of them.
But it's that's impossible.
For instance, in a continue section
set up
where you can add two sets of possible
policies because the objections
are continuous, a third number
is infinite for every dimension.
So that's made infinite by infinite
and so on.
So it's it's a huge
a is a huge dimensionality in space.
So instead here we, we make the action
part of the or the inference process.
So we want
we want to have a separate model
that tells you to tell us what's
what's the action
to to take at every step. And
the I
what I said
that we obtain an actual entropy term
and that's because we in, in choosing
the best action so in, in trying to,
to match our actions to the one that we,
we should actually prefer, we,
we think it like we don't have
a preference this over action.
So we would.
So for instance, I, if I want to reach
a certain state environment
so if I want to to go from this room
to to the kitchen,
maybe I don't care what's the,
what's the shortest word,
the shorter passes, I just care about
getting there at some point
or I don't care about going left
or going round right now.
When I when I get off of my chair,
I just want to to go where I need to go.
So we don't
we don't place a prior over the action.
We just say whatever action is fine
as long as it brings you
the fastest as possible to the goal
that the fastest thing
is not even by the action itself,
but but by minimizing the free energy
so we don't want a preference
over the actions we wanted.
We want the free energy
to be the first spot.
And so the actions are we
some a unit for distribution over them
and what remains is just an entropy.
So it will be a real divergence between
the queue
over the action given the states
and the this party,
which basically becomes an entropy value.
If you, if you you're some user constant
because it's just
subtracting a constant to that and the.
Yeah, the switching to the to the other
part of the equation.
So what does it mean to us
this discourse center here.
So is adding constant term useful.
So I don't know if there's any other
useful custom term that we could get.
So the mathematically speaking,
having a constant
having gone up from an upper bound
because of the constant
building beyond me, because you're
minimizing the same objective.
But then on top of that,
we apply the contrastive,
the contrastive approximation
and that leads to another
the upper bound and the as I said,
there are some implication of this.
We get to maybe
a better representation, but
are we getting farther from the
from the actual objectives?
So from my point of view,
as long as we achieve
something that is actually better,
it doesn't really matter how far are we
from the actual surprise and see now.
So in any case,
we will always get some kind of
amortization or approximation
and we will probably never get 100%
close to there to the surprise value.
So because we don't have a perfect model,
so a perfect model of the word
doesn't exist, it's it's impossible
to imagine that we can model every
details of the environment,
even if we are with a billion
machine learning parameter.
And it's impossible
to think that we will always act
perfectly and always get in the,
in the perfect route to go
using the always optimal action,
especially because there is always
some uncertainty in the environment
and there's a lot of things
that we, we normally want to ignore
in our everyday lives.
So a lot of things
there is not actually important
to the capturing the word model or action
y it's not always important
beyond just percentile
correcting over movement
and so in the action,
we think the important thing is that we,
we get close to the goal.
So I will say, yeah,
if there are any other term
that we at the other center
or just any other modification
that we could do to there
to the free energy function
or that actually leads to better results
without compromising the original goal
of minimizing the energy.
I think that's that would be a good way
to uh, to address
some of the issues
that we, that we currently have with,
we've actually been, for instance,
that could actually lead to,
to improving the performance of the,
the artificial implementation
of active inference
significantly.
So that's also why I think that's
taking advantage of some lessons that,
that we learned from reinforcement
learning is actually useful
in acting inference as well because the
there has been a ton of research
about the way to amortize this thing or
approximating something better or
train a better deep learning model for
some solving some very specific aspect.
And I think the objective inference
research there
to benefit from this,
to take inspiration from this.
And maybe if I make that's good.
Or can you go back to the slide
with the action
uh. It's one.
Yeah.
So, so maybe to make it easier here for
or maybe people
that are less familiar with reinforcement
learning but are coming
from a more active instance background.
So in, in terms of
active inference,
but on a scale
first thing, let's look at it.
This is basically something
that you should not do
source.
So so basically
what happens here
is that we see action inference
more like a habitual thing,
like a, a moment the state
or I think I'm in the state, so therefore
I can just infer my action results.
But it's kind of you become habituated.
So I explained this hundreds of times
and it's always this outcome.
So I just stop planning
and I just amortize
this action into in the more playful C
So that's basically the kind of
the mechanism
that that we apply here in order
to avoid planning all the time
because that's, that's the,
the tricky part.
We have too much options to plan
so we don't want to do this.
So we just say let's amortize it
from stuff,
which basically means that this
A, this or Q or a broken procedure.
It's not only over stays
but also over actions.
And then so the action entropy
just falls out
by introducing the,
the action in the user.
So it's not that we
magically add an action action and return
to the simulation.
It just comes out because of having
the actions esports over there
but so did the my, the, this also means
that we have an approximate there
over actual selection and this works
in at
least three or four string problems
because they're.
Yeah, your goal is always
the same, doesn't it shift.
It's not a, it's also not a
if you, if you think back on on
biological agents look like a complex
distribution to maintain homeostasis
basically just yet.
This is the reward.
This is very good. It's
it's always the same thing.
So this basically means that
your environments very enriched with this
this agency which also reinforcement
learning solutions to their agents
is exactly the environment is used for
I can amortize what what I have to do
because if I know my status
I know they have to do basically
things so change I guess
if you have another environment in which
this is not the case
where you could be in a certain state
and you would still have multiple options
to do and you and you can only
you can only
really know what to do
by planning ahead through by first.
So search for information
on what's happening
and in these kind of environments,
I, I think that's
what position treatments
will help you a lot.
Are you going to do it
just by amortizing.
So it's, it's a trick device to,
to allow it to work
in this kind of environment because you
you have to benchmark against some things
and you have to be on board there.
It's so
keep in mind it's not the silver bullet
that will always work.
We do deviate from vanilla extract
insurance here costs
section inference s like
we just want to learn habits
you don't want to plan.
But this also means that there might be
situations where it will not work
and then it's not due to active insurance
or for the energy principle
that's not working.
It's more like the
the crude approximation
here by which things might not working.
Well.
That's interesting
about which training environments favor,
what kind of algorithms and then how
that shapes the perception of different
algorithms like the navigation task.
What if there was a fuel tank
or there was a
larger space
that was going to require like multiple
foraging information,
foraging trips, for example.
And so then the sort of single minded
seeker is going to
just die fast,
but then something that's able
to actually engage in planning wouldn't.
So that was a little bit like to those
who are familiar with active inference.
And then here's a variance
on what we've seen before.
How about for those who are more familiar
with the dreamer architect
or reinforcement learning?
What makes active inference,
active inference, and how is it different
Well.
I think
they are
they're largely similar, let's say.
I think that would be the starting point
because
both awesome people think about
what's the difference.
But I think the the the main point
that we should
rather stress more as an active interest
community is that there are a lot
more similarities between reinforcement
learning and active inference.
I would say that
active inference is a bit more general
than reinforcement learning.
In the sense that on the one hand
we don't use the reward function per say,
but we relax that the bit as in
we just have a distribution over
preferred outcomes, which is a bit
more general, I would say.
And then the second thing
is that instead of
starting off from the free energy
principle as in
this is the objective that we want to
minimize you also gets the,
the extrinsic
value term here,
which is exactly the same thing
as for the reinforcement
learning agents optimize.
So if you only look at extrinsic value,
your agents will also do this.
But the, the,
the added value
I would say comes in the information
gain terms and this will only give you
an additional benefit
in environments
where there is information to date.
And this is not your typical
reinforcement learning environment.
But if you look at, for example,
the teammates mouths from golfers,
then these are typical environments
where you can actually show
that if you only go for extrinsic value
you won't you will be acting suboptimal.
So you can actually prove
almost that in some environments
over there
looking at the extrinsic value,
given the correct model
of the environment active inference rule.
I think the crucial
thing that
we need to research on is
how do you get to the of the cortex
or the optimal model of your results
enrich
by optimizing your expected actually
you're doing a sensible planning
and this is still largely unresolved
with our models.
We are taking steps in that direction.
But as you can see,
there are lots of issues
to just find the correct model
because if you just look at the models
the likelihood based model
should be perfectly fine,
but based by the way
you optimize in practice,
then you see all kinds of problems like,
okay, this, this, this little pixel
is actually the most important pixel.
Look over the thing.
And that does not appear
so in my lost function.
So that's why everything collapses.
So in theory, it should work,
but there are a lot of practical problems
to find the correct model
that pays attention
to the correct details
or to correct your observations.
And this is still that
this is something that is shared with
model based reinforcement
learning as well as active inference
and I think there is a
huge opportunity to find new
techniques that
can and put forward both both fields.
And we also showed this
like the contrastive drama
in the districting environment. Also
improves performance
on the normal dreams.
So by having a technique
that lets you build a better model,
any model based algorithm will work.
And effective inference
has this special notion
of also take into account information
gain in environments
where you might be denser
to ensure your status.
So that's that's where it can prevail.
But I think in most of the benchmark
environments
of similar days,
especially in machine learning,
you probably don't need these external.
So you probably get away
with just maximizing rewards
which is in fact
also an active inference agents.
And to some sense, if of course
if it's if it's I'm talking about a model
based like dream agents
in this case, of course, the model three
ones are
these are the differences.
They, they don't need to model the goal.
But at least for mobile based
reinforcement learning agents, I think
it's pretty similar
to what a negative influence to
in these environments
Thank you.
Tim Pietro, anything you'd add to
yeah.
I would like to
to discuss
one aspect of three merit
that's been a bit overlooked
is the fact that it makes this
amortization similar and it's also
similar to what we have done.
So yeah, this is this we learn a policy
basically we own an action network
that provides the correct state
in the correct action
for every state, but
it is the key step
to actually brings us closer to the acted
in principle relation is that we,
we imagine several steps in the future.
So it is true that we don't
evaluate and long policies
in the over
other times that we have these
prior
about
action it is given by our action network.
But it is also true
that given the fact that we
evaluate the state three
we expect to see and then from there
we re start doing the
the actual optimization process.
We actually get closer to the
optimization scheme of active importance.
In particular, there is a
paper called Sophisticated Inference
that discussed this when you,
when you actually take an action
and then you reimagine
from that step what's going to up
what's going to happen.
There are some implication of this,
but that we are not completely drifting
away from the
from the original activity story
because of this is just a different way
of doing the action selection process.
Similar in that indeed
the three results are very close to
the active inference itself.
Poole Thank you.
I wrote down, if you don't know where
you prefer to go, your lost drive fast.
If you know how to get there,
figure it out if you don't
and then re-assess continually.
And I hope that conveys
some of the similarities and differences
Do you have any final comments
This is a very
interesting line of research and
we really appreciate this model stream.
Hope to see you in the future.
Or should I say we expect and prefer it.
But thanks again, Pietro and Tim.
This is really awesome.
Welcome.
Thanks for having us.
Thank us.
Have a good day, everyone.
Have a good day.
Everyone, have a good day.
Everyone have a good day.
Everyone, have a good day, everyone.